it is almost unacceptable in almost all
societies around the world to downsize
your home sell your home or apartment
and get a smaller that is like no
whereas for me I've loved the last 20
years of my career where I do things and
then do less versions of them because I
need to save money for something people
are worried about what people perceive
you had Alexis now you have a Toyota
that's a problem whereas for me if we
can ever eliminate that stigma in
society we will have a much happier
world because then people will do that
save dollars to be able to go after
their dream I can't be a singer and do
open mics and not make money I've got to
keep being this corporate executive well
you don't have to if you can downsize
but then imagine people with families I
have incredible empathy if you're a
mother or father and you're the
breadwinner to the organization and you
come home and now that your kids have to
share a room who wants to come home and
see their seven and four-year-old go
from their own rooms in a nice backyard
and we're going to move to a
neighborhood that might be not as nice
no backyard and you're sharing a room
that is very challenging the problem is
I think if someone is living unhappy
much bigger challenge or in front